[Music]
in sexy times news sexy time these are
sexy times submitted by bucket of fried
chicken
Oh fried chicken make it with fried
chicken that's sexy oh no no right
chicken when you're naked yes yes he's
like finally someone who gets all right
men reveal how they know when they're
partners once said wow I gotta hear this
one yeah cuz it's a mystery to me I just
don't know I know when I want it
I just never know when the girl wants no
Sam I'm like wait that's not it kind of
rapey what do you do when you know you
want it what do you do to give her signs
you just say it or do you like do like
more romantic I go like this I think it
depends on what stage of the
relationship you're in true cuz I think
the more time spent the more comfortable
you are
I got your Matt in that part of your
relationship right now
now how they wanna do it like the more
I'm sure you guys know this you might
you have to kind of schedule out and
plan your [ __ ] like you can't like
[ __ ] wait tomorrow I gotta get up at 7
a.m. is it responsible to [ __ ] tonight
or can we really like you know when
you're in the first stages you're like I
don't care if I'm gonna sleep three
hours I'll [ __ ] that's not worth it I
can't wait get did I fall asleep I will
fall asleep no no if we [ __ ] I will fall
asleep so I'm like so if I'm doing
something right I can't [ __ ] first if I
got a Red Bull in the fridge maybe it's
like dude I'm falling asleep ever Oh
like it's like if we have a movie to go
to let's watch the movie first and then
do it like we can't be spontaneous and
do it before cuz I'll fall asleep like
that that's why being an adult is the
worst is when your teenager it's like no
sweat at all times
there's no responsibilities you can go
to Taco Bell or everything on the menu
and still [ __ ] you're fine
true think about this now you have to
like it's like wait what did I eat
because it's [ __ ] me
I got a gas pocket right here
it's like you can't you can't just just
whip it out and do it it I might have a
salad coz I'm a [ __ ]
exactly for me it's cheese right and I
love Mexican food like nobody else all
dairy adjust cheese I mostly just cheese
I mean I don't sit there and drink a
glass of milk during dinner yeah
no yeah ice cream I don't really [ __ ]
with ice cream at all ever not really
yeah just cheese mostly can't get a
pizza or dope it's the same thing yeah
yeah I know what do you think I'm also
gonna pee all the time I definitely
can't eat cheese before sex man if I eat
a pizza before sex well all I'm having
sex I've got it you're gonna burn you
know it's not you what are those lactaid
pills pretty much so it's really
uncomfortable when you're trying to have
sex you know you're trying not to fart
okay but your reaction to cheese is like
not human like you oh you know when you
don't eat it without those pills like
you're on the floor about to like yeah
nine-one-one
[ __ ] you're a little [ __ ] on guys hey
man it wasn't always like that all right
here in the military dude they'd be like
toughen up [ __ ] [ __ ] eat up your
vomit or if y'all want to be around me
right now after you some cheese that's
all good I mean that's your I'm good no
my thing you do is temperature too man
it's like if it's too hot I can't [ __ ]
if it's too cold I can sweat and then
Nicky if it and then if it gets too too
cold
Nicky doesn't want to [ __ ] she's so cold
and then we have to get her naked and I
have to like crawl under the sheets with
her because I have to be her blanket I'm
like all right let's go and you're her
blanket which is crazy you're tiny man
it's like a [ __ ] napkin blanket yeah
so on reddit there was a tree that was
titled ladies of reddit what subtle
clues do you give your man when you're
in the mood and so a lot of people
responded this one I thought was
hilarious this first one says my wife is
super subtle I can tell by how the
goodnight kiss goes if I get a peck on
the lips I know nothing's happening if I
gave you a longer kiss then I still know
know that nothing's happening because
nothing ever happens pretty what you
think really
next one says not a lady but my wife
likes to seductively block out 30
minutes on her day planner a week in
advance the next one I lead him by the
hand into the bedroom and whisper those
magic words into his ears into his ear
the baby's asleep then we have very
quiet sex while trying not to make eye
contact with a dog
[ __ ] Daniel Steel novel so responsive
that one saying sometimes my wife and I
throw a cartoon on to distract our kids
for a few minutes oh my weekend some
afternoon delights its conditioned me to
get aroused by the paw patrol theme song
this is the real [ __ ] okay that they
don't tell you in Twilight and all this
other stuff that you watch like this is
real love that is real
next one if the TV is on I'll go
upstairs to our room and get naked then
I use my phone to play Careless Whisper
downstairs through youtube I always hear
alas and then him running up the stairs
that's great she's a comedian yeah this
next one says if she's playing a video
game
I'll leave my boobs on his back or head
out of my kill streak the next one I
stand next to him while he's on the
computer game and shout sex it's tribal
Blunt yeah I basically just ripped my
shirt off not so subtle but does tend to
get results Oh
spends a lot of money on shirt yeah I
like to see that sometime like she hole
Colvin's our shirt open that's it yeah
thanks a lot my husband knows when I'm
in the mood because I hug him and say
hello
I suck at coming on to him some of these
are dark then no but why because that
was really dark just sad that to me is
really dirt next one my ex-wife used to
hug me and light leave dry hump me and
go in unison with the thrust that was
her way of telling them that's pretty
funny interesting that's like a dog yeah
doesn't stop this one is by someone with
the handle nympho nerd saying seeing as
I'm always in the mood it's up to him to
tell me when he's in the mood usually
though if I want to get him in the mood
I just speak in a British accent almost
always guaranteed to get me laid Wow
I think that's pretty hot role-playing
it's very specific nikki has a certain
voice that she does and I [ __ ] bed
it's like an operator voice like sexy
woman on the phone thing I love all fake
things so yeah even better because it's
like it's not really oh yeah we do
actually Oh interesting scenario um I
don't want to do shtick but I'm not
gonna do it I wanted I go on the cable
man but that's not true she really likes
just to be completely dominated so I do
that
I do yeah interesting what the cheese my
book what if the older you get the rolls
kind of get boring so like you you go
through all the normal rules right like
the nurse the maid the teacher all those
and then you're like you're running out
and you're just like olive I don't want
to do the [ __ ] teacher thing anymore
we already done it then you have to go
into the weird [ __ ] now it's like theme
park what seemed percussion like Mickey
Mouse let me know when you get to that
stage or she let us know I can see you
getting a little more violent like over
time there's no more role-playing but
it's more slapping and then when you're
slapping too much and it gets to like
close-minded she is about violence
during sex don't you like to just like
the little hair pulling yeah little baby
I want to spar Jess I just just want sex
I put can you put these like gloves on I
just want to play with you right now
just you are with me you're McGregor
I'll be Mayweather let's hug
it's true they did a lot you know the
next one they wrote my fiancee just
looks at me and says casually do you
want to put the penis in the vagina then
I know it's go time
Wow very subtle Nexen says mine actually
is pretty subtle I usually wear minimal
or natural makeup my husband thinks
thick dark eye makeup is naughty and
sexy when I'm in the mood I go dark in
my eye even killing the sultry look and
he knows exactly what it means
that's why dads are always like you're
not leaving the house with that makeup
like to their daughters because they
think it's [ __ ] - I never understood
that that makes sense
oh yeah yeah it's like you're not
walking out getting [ __ ] you know
looking like that cuz you're moving like
they think do you're stressing out with
you guys talking about this right now
I'm like la la la la la oh I hear that
[ __ ] it's time for you to pay for your
sins oh you know every time they talk a
lot Isaac growing up having sex I'm like
no I'm like two months out of having a
girl right now it's [ __ ] crazy I
don't hear that [ __ ] see that's how I
know I'm not fit to be a dad yet because
when I think oh I can't wait to have
kids so when they have sex I could be
like yeah once you actually do have a
can - you're not gonna be saying that
probably most likely and we all know
[ __ ] heads - like somewhere or like
somebody who does something weird during
sex or something so yeah but if they all
have moms somewhere who looked at them
the same way you look at Isaac so like
one day your little baby boy they could
be known as the hymen breaker
we don't know like people are dude you
know who beats it up it's [ __ ] eyes
we get old they're gonna look at us like
oh I want to grow some mouth like
hardcore I think it's great I wish my
parents were [ __ ] oh my god no they're
probably not but I know how does Nikki
what you know that she was Isaac um well
usually I let her know because it
suddenly gets real cold in the room like
she's just sitting there in her computer
she's like she knows it's on because I'd
crank that [ __ ] up cuz I get hot quick
oh you prep crap the room yeah and then
that's how you let her know that's how I
let her know that the moves on Wow
that's [ __ ] cool that's serious
company because I get so hot dude I get
real hot quit oh yeah I could be your
line winter is coming that's good so I
know that show but I know that lines
anyway thank you actually don't know it
just happens it's like magic yeah but I
don't know I think before when we when
we were earlier on in the relationship
we would talk about it a lot and then
like when we see each other because like
we lived all the way far away it was
like we couldn't keep our hands off each
other but then like now it's it's a
different dynamic as we've lived
together and then it changes I'm sorry I
just remembered last time I was here
last week just just looked at me and
she's like you know I talk about sex
more than I have sex yeah
lesson for you guys if you want to have
a lot of sex stay single or always in a
dating phase yeah yeah don't you live
together it changes it because there's
no like mystique behind it like it you
still have sex but it's like that's not
the that's not the thing you look
forward to doing it's other things that
happen you can't wait to watch Survivor
exactly that becomes like why like you
know is American Horror Story on yeah
let's go watch it this
yeah I simply just get too lazy or like
ya know Chilean just the Netflix bar you
guys just gotta make new goals I mean
when you live together maybe one day
you'll buy a house together and then
you're gonna say alright I want to
[ __ ] every room possible then you
start making goals alright we're gonna
[ __ ] the living room and [ __ ] the
garage we're gonna [ __ ] the pool and
do all this I'm not going to your pool
party you're you're married though right
yeah do you do that no no you don't I
hope you guys enjoyed this video for
more please subscribe to our Channel and
you can check out the last video right
here
[Music]